i am over the movies i just watched this
film so
emerald and carrie i don't know what to
do just but bow down i'm not even sure
how to react to this i'm just
in awe of both of you just absolutely
amazing and emerald
your directorial debut i'm so excited
you're you're the writer of this
i mean where does the story of casey
stem from do you pull from your own
personal experience from other people's
stories i think you know it
really feels like something that was
just born from the the whole
culture that we grew up with yeah you
know the the thing that that
i said right from the get-go to everyone
who came on board this one was that
there is nothing that happens in this
movie
you know that we haven't seen in a very
different way
in comedy movies and tv shows of the
last 10
15 years i mean you know getting girls
drunk
and picking them up at bars and at
parties
it was just certainly when i was growing
up was just
a plot line you know usually in a kind
of male-driven
comedy so so really it's just it's just
about kind of reframing that
and and i kind of i guess i was
interested in what happens to these
women in these movies when they go home
you know what happens after they they've
had their two lines in a scene
and they go home so it sort of probably
started somewhere like that and
and kind of built from there i guess and
carrie
uh you as casey i blown away by your
performance
and uh it is refreshing to see you in a
character like this and you're invested
right from the beginning to the end and
you get that margot robbie kind of
harley quinn feel at the end as well
what was it like for you to bring her to
life on screen
and was it refreshing for you to take on
a role like this
yeah i mean it was just so nice to be
surrounded by comedians
it was just i just remember like two
days into filming saying to emeralds my
gosh i can't believe how much we're
laughing at work this is
so nice um it was it was different and
it felt really exciting and also just
i hadn't ever read a script like this
you know there was just
it just has so much and the character is
so rich and she's just
there's so much underneath the surface
um and
and then when emerald started pulling
together this incredible cast it just
felt like
you know it kept building um so
yeah i felt very very lucky to to get my
hands on it
what a twist taking good guys and
turning them into bad guys it was really
interesting the way you did that and
there was a pivotal moment when you see
casey and the dean with connie britton
which she was absolutely amazing in it
too where it
it's a powerful moment because like you
said it's that whole you know
the boys will be boys but then you
empathize
with both characters so this is a
question to both of you
what kind of conversation especially
cara you're a mom i'm a mom what kind of
conversations
do you want people to have after
watching this film
um i mean i think you know
certainly i think emerald including you
know
the dean character and allison breeze
character
um was so
important um you know there's nothing
black and white about this and there's
nothing
uh there's no straight up villains and
um i think that's true to life i think
that's the kind of
um oftentimes we try and sort of decide
who the baddies are um and i think it's
just so much more complicated that
and and you're not defined by the one
thing that you do in your life
um and so i think you know i think
there's an element to which
passing judgment on people and
counseling them for their entire lives
may not be the way
forward i'm not speaking specifically to
you know um
any kind of criminal act but i think
it's important these conversations carry
on and we can talk really openly about
them
um i think these are kind of
conversations that i you know you just
would never have had with your
family or your parents you know growing
up i certainly wouldn't have done it
just
i you know and i think this is an
opportunity for those conversations to
start you know there's
it's always when art holds up a mirror
and allows conversations to begin that's
you know
one of the great reasons for making it
um
and emerald uh finally i just want to
say i had a chance to interview the
whole cast of the crown i'm a huge fan
and i didn't get a chance to talk to you
uh and you are just fantastic in season
four what does it mean
that the duchess of cornwall actually
watches the crown and does that kind of
freak you out a little bit
does she yes she actually watches
that is that is nerve-wracking i didn't
realize that but um
look i hope she i hope she approves
i love it thank you to both of you and i
will see you during the oscars take care
everyone
you